Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的内容之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“追求经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Ever been told you shouldn't be a psychologist? In this eye-opening episode,
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。有没有人告诉过你不应该成为心理学家？在这一期令人大开眼界的节目中，
we are debunking the seven most common misconceptions that might be holding you back or making you question your compatibility with a career in psychology. Get ready to challenge those doubts and discover the truth about what it really takes to thrive in this incredibly rewarding profession. Let's break down the barriers and redefine your perspective on becoming a psychologist. Stay tuned. Hope you find it useful. Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. But would I be if I had received other messages about myself as part of my journey when I was an aspiring psychologist? Would I be if I had already
我们将揭穿七个最常见的误区，这些误区可能正在阻碍你，或者让你怀疑自己是否适合从事心理学职业。准备好挑战这些疑虑，发现在这个极具成就感的职业中真正需要什么。让我们打破障碍，重新定义你对成为心理学家的看法。敬请期待。希望这期节目对你有帮助。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是Marianne Trent博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。但如果我在追求心理学家的道路上，曾收到过关于我自己的其他评价，我还会是现在的我吗？如果我当时已经
believed certain things about myself, my capabilities, my opportunities as I was growing up. Let's take a little bit of a look into seven reasons people might think they're incompatible with this fantastic career of psychology. Reason number one, you won't cope, not with your mental health or not with what you've been through or actually what I've recognised and seen in you lately since you've responded to this, that or the other crisis in your personal life. I just think this is horrendous. told to people by people who are supposed to be qualified, who are supposed to believe in capacity for change and growth, you know, potentially to be the people that are supposed to be helping support employees through episodes of crisis. This cropped up recently for me as part of a Facebook group that I'm in, and somebody's supervisor had actually told them this and I was horrified because for me as a supervisor I think my job is well how can I help support you through this difficult time
在成长过程中对自己、自己的能力和机会形成了某些固有的看法，我还会是现在的我吗？让我们来看看人们认为自己不适合从事心理学这一伟大职业的七个原因。第一个原因：你承受不了，无论是心理健康方面，还是你所经历的事情，或者实际上是我最近从你身上观察到的——自从你应对了个人生活中的这样或那样的危机之后。我觉得这太可怕了。这些话出自那些本应具备专业资格、本应相信改变和成长能力的人之口，你知道，他们本应是那些在员工经历危机时提供支持的人。这事最近在我加入的一个Facebook群组中出现了，某人的主管竟然对他们说了这种话，我感到非常震惊，因为作为一名主管，我认为我的工作是：我该如何帮助你度过这段困难时期，
how can I be my optimal best to give you what you need to you know if not thrive through this period, survive through this period, so that you can go on to have growth and to come out the other side. And really, one of the main reasons I would say that I started this podcast was to provide listeners and the watchers on YouTube, subscribe and like if you are watching on YouTube with an alternative narrative. If you are in a team or supervised or know of psychologists who don't seem to want to fuel you, to help you, to, you know, sprinkle compassion around liberally, to make you believe that you can do this or to inspire you to want to do this you know you're not seeing that good practice that's making you go yes this is the reason I'm doing this now this is one of the reasons I put the podcast together to give you hope to give you
我该如何发挥最佳状态，为你提供你所需要的东西，让你不仅能度过这段时期，甚至能从中成长，并最终走出困境。说实话，我创办这个播客的主要原因之一，就是为听众和YouTube观众（如果你在YouTube上观看，请订阅并点赞）提供一种替代性的叙事。如果你所在的团队、主管或认识的心理学家似乎不想激励你、帮助你，不想慷慨地给予关怀，不想让你相信你能做到，或者不想激励你去做这件事，你知道，你没有看到那种让你觉得“是的，这就是我做这件事的原因”的良好实践，这就是我制作这个播客的原因之一，为了给你希望，给你
an alternative perspective so you know the idea that this is being told to people is really horrifying for me. And it made me think about the time that I was doing a master's, distance learning whilst working full time. I had had a car accident. I had back problems. I was seeing an osteopath and physiotherapist for due to the car accident. I'd broken up with a partner, a long-term partner at that time. Things were really tricky for me at that time, but at no point did anybody say, this isn't for you. You know, I guess because I held it together, I was doing still what I needed to do, but it was a hard time in my life. But that was
一种不同的视角。所以，人们被告知这些话，对我来说真的很可怕。这让我想起我读硕士的时候，一边全职工作，一边进行远程学习。当时我出了车祸，背部有问题，因为车祸在看整骨医生和理疗师。那时我和一位长期伴侣分手了。那段时间对我来说真的很棘手，但从来没有人说过“这不适合你”。你知道，我想是因为我坚持住了，我依然在做我需要做的事，但那是我生命中一段艰难的时光。但那正是
the cycle of applications that I got onto clinical training. And I do believe it made me a better clinician for navigating those experiences. And it also made me reflect upon one of my dear friends and colleagues, Dr. Cara Davey, who lost a child, who gave birth to a stillborn daughter. And it had been incredibly difficult, incredibly painful. And of course, continues to be as well, you know, it shapes us and our experience and what we think of the world and how we perceive risk and, you know, our hope and all of that. But, you know, had that happened to her in the earlier stage of her career, she might have felt that she wasn't, you know, cut out for psychology or she wouldn't cope with it. Or maybe somebody might even have told her that. Because, of course, some certain key events will feel like they decimate us personally and professionally because they're big, because they, you know, you will see this either in your own lives as you care about or in colleagues friends sometimes big massive things happen to
我申请临床培训的那一轮。我确实相信，正是因为经历了那些体验，我才成为了一名更好的临床医生。这也让我想起了我的一位挚友兼同事，Cara Davey博士，她失去了一个孩子，生下了一个死胎。那段经历极其艰难、极其痛苦。当然，这种痛苦一直都在，你知道，它塑造了我们，塑造了我们的经历，塑造了我们对世界的看法，以及我们如何感知风险、我们的希望等等。但是，你知道，如果这件事发生在她职业生涯的早期，她可能会觉得她不适合心理学，或者她无法应对。甚至可能有人会告诉她这些。因为，当然，某些关键事件会让我们在个人和职业层面感到崩溃，因为它们太重大了，因为，你知道，你会在你关心的人的生活中，或者在同事朋友身上看到这一点，有时会发生巨大的事情，
humans and we have to be able to navigate through that and you know you learn a lot through adversity is what I would say and it might well mean that you end up making that your clinical specialism, as Cara has done. So Cara does lots of work for people that have had loss pregnancies, loss of children and late miscarriages or stillbirths. And it's incredibly useful. And I know the people that work with her find it really useful that she's had similar experience. Whilst you don't need to get hit by a bus to know that it hurts, it sure does help for your empathy. But yeah, in terms of mental health, I think if your mental health is well managed and you are accessing the appropriate treatment and mental health support if needed.
人类必须能够应对这些。我会说，你通过逆境学到了很多，这很可能意味着你最终会将其作为你的临床专长，就像Cara所做的那样。所以Cara为那些经历过流产、失去孩子、晚期流产或死产的人做了大量工作。这非常有意义。我知道与她共事的人发现，她有过类似的经历非常有帮助。虽然你不需要被车撞了才知道疼，但这确实有助于提升你的同理心。但是，是的，就心理健康而言，我认为如果你的心理健康管理得当，并且在需要时获得了适当的治疗和心理健康支持，
There's no reason you can't be a psychologist. It might be that you use supervision and ongoing therapy, and you stay mindful, and you know, hopefully, by this stage in your life, what keeps you well, what helps you thrive. And so it's going to be, like any of us, it's going to be your responsibility to make sure that as much as possible, you're getting that balance that means that it's possible. And it also made me think about a story that someone had told me about when they were an assistant psychologist, and experienced two massive traumas in the same year, a loss of a fiancé and a loss of a father. That's a lot to go through. And that person was told by a supervisor, I don't think you're going
没有理由你不能成为一名心理学家。可能你需要督导和持续的治疗，保持正念，并且你知道，希望到了人生的这个阶段，你知道什么能让你保持健康，什么能让你茁壮成长。所以，就像我们所有人一样，确保尽可能获得那种平衡将是你的责任，这意味着这是可能的。这也让我想起了一个人告诉我的故事，当他们还是助理心理学家时，在同一年经历了两次巨大的创伤：未婚夫去世和父亲去世。这经历太多了。而那个人被主管告知：“我不认为你
to be psychologically strong enough to be a psychologist. I think you ought to think about doing something different, which is just incredibly galling. How can you expect anybody to go through that sort of year and not be impacted upon it? But I know that that person is now a qualified psychologist and does a really, really good job. And so, you know, whatever stage of your career you are, as you're listening to this, just be kind, just be mindful, be supportive. You know, let's not be a hater. Let's know what we know about mental health, about, you know, difficult times, about being supportive. And let's think, you know, of course, you might have clinical concerns about somebody's ability to do a job. That is a different issue. You know, if you don't feel like they are doing things enough to be able to safeguard risk, and, you know, that is a separate
在心理上足够强大，能成为一名心理学家。我认为你应该考虑做点别的。”这真是令人愤慨。你怎么能指望一个人经历那样的一年而不受影响呢？但我知道那个人现在已经是一名合格的心理学家，并且工作做得非常好。所以，你知道，无论你处于职业生涯的哪个阶段，当你听到这些时，请保持善良，保持正念，给予支持。你知道，让我们不要成为那种刻薄的人。让我们运用我们对心理健康、困难时期和支持他人的了解。让我们想一想，当然，你可能会对某人的工作能力有临床上的担忧。那是另一回事。你知道，如果你觉得他们做得不够，无法保障风险，那么，这是一个单独的
issue. But, you know, the reason to exclude somebody from the career of psychology is not just because they've had a mental health history. It isn't because they've experienced trauma in their own lives. You know, this is a case by case basis. And maybe someone needs a period of sick leave. And that's okay. That doesn't make them a failure, doesn't make them not cut out for the career of psychology, whichever discipline they go into. You know, let's think about supporting our colleagues. So that was reason one. Reason two is that somebody is either diagnosed or, you know, identifies with or even just has traits of, doesn't want to go through diagnosis. Issues of neurodiversity, that might be
问题。但是，你知道，仅仅因为某人有心理健康史，就将其排除在心理学职业之外是不对的。仅仅因为他们在自己的生活中经历过创伤，也不是理由。你知道，这是具体情况具体分析的。也许有人需要一段时间的病假。那没关系。这并不意味着他们失败了，并不意味着他们不适合心理学职业，无论他们进入哪个学科。你知道，让我们考虑支持我们的同事。所以这是第一个原因。第二个原因：某人被诊断出，或者认同，甚至只是具有神经多样性的特征，而不想经历诊断过程。这可能是
autism spectrum condition, disorder, whatever you call it or refer to it as. It might be ADHD, it might be dyslexia, it might be dyspraxia, it might be a whole range of things. And for that, I would say, you know, let's not be too ableist here. You know, our clients that we work with are going to be very diverse and you know why shouldn't our mental health services be made up of people that are equally diverse and colourful that's what I believe you know variety is the spice of life and how can we learn more about shaping our services and making sure they really are fit for purpose if we are not talking the talk and walking the walk and listening to the voices of people who know what it is going to be that makes a difference and this might be a really nice opportunity to tell you about a very exciting book project that is coming with two of my colleagues,
自闭症谱系障碍，无论你怎么称呼它。可能是多动症（ADHD）、阅读障碍、动作协调障碍，或者其他一系列问题。对于这一点，我会说，我们不要在这里表现得太歧视残障人士。你知道，我们服务的客户将是非常多样化的，你知道，为什么我们的心理健康服务不能由同样多样化和丰富多彩的人组成呢？这就是我的信念。你知道，多样性是生活的调味品。如果我们不言行一致，不倾听那些知道什么才是真正有意义的人的声音，我们怎么能学到更多关于塑造服务并确保它们真正适用呢？这可能是一个非常好的机会，可以告诉你一个非常令人兴奋的书籍项目，它是由我的两位同事共同完成的，
one of whom you've met already, Nikita, who is currently a first year clinical psychology trainee, and Dr. Vicky Jarvis, who is a qualified clinical psychologist. And very excitingly, this book now has a title. It is becoming a thing and it's beautiful it is called an autistic anthology neuro narratives of mental health professionals and if you're listening to this and you think yes I would love to get involved there is still time so this book is for people that either identify as having autism or have a diagnosis of autism. That is what we are looking at. So if that describes you and you'd love to tell your story in a collective anthology, please do get in contact with me and we can do our best to get you in the book, which we should
其中一位你已经见过了，Nikita，她目前是一名一年级临床心理学实习生，还有Vicky Jarvis博士，她是一名合格的临床心理学家。非常令人兴奋的是，这本书现在有了书名。它正在成型，非常漂亮，书名叫《自闭症选集：心理健康专业人士的神经叙事》（An Autistic Anthology: Neuro-narratives of Mental Health Professionals）。如果你正在听这个节目，并且想：“是的，我很想参与其中”，现在还有时间。所以这本书是为那些认同自己患有自闭症或被诊断出患有自闭症的人准备的。这就是我们关注的对象。所以，如果这描述了你，并且你很乐意在集体选集中讲述你的故事，请务必与我联系，我们会尽力让你进入这本书，我们应该
hopefully be on track for publishing in the summer. We need to break that stigma, you know, that people with issues of neurodiversity cannot be working in mental health. So you don't have to be a psychologist to contribute to that book. But if you work in mental health, we would love to be able to feature you in that if you've got a story you would like to tell. So yeah, you know, somebody with ADHD, for somebody with dyslexia, for example, you might need some additional support, you might need some planning, some more proofreading. But these are options that are available within universities. And when you are employed, there are options for access to work and inclusion and all of that. So, you know, if you can have the dream, you can shoot your shot. Just because those issues might be around for you doesn't mean you can't
希望能在夏天出版。我们需要打破那种“神经多样性问题的人不能在心理健康领域工作”的污名。所以你不必是心理学家也能为那本书做出贡献。但如果你在心理健康领域工作，如果你有想讲述的故事，我们很乐意让你参与其中。所以，是的，你知道，对于患有ADHD的人，或者患有阅读障碍的人，例如，你可能需要一些额外的支持，你可能需要一些规划，一些校对。但这些是大学里可以提供的选择。当你被雇佣时，也有关于工作获取和包容性的选择。所以，你知道，如果你有梦想，你就可以去尝试。仅仅因为这些问题可能存在于你身上，并不意味着你不能
or you shouldn't be a psychologist. Reason number three, perhaps you're already a parent or you'd like to become a parent in the next couple of years. And for that, I would say, don't forget, we did interview Rose Dunstan, who at the time was a trainee clinical psychologist, and also a parent. Do check that episode out if you think you might find that useful. That was episode 25. You know, I am a parent and I had my children after I finished training, primarily probably because I hadn't met a partner that I wanted to have children with earlier. Otherwise, my own journey may have looked different. And all I can speak from really is my experience of parenting now, which is post qualification. And children do shift your priorities. They do make things a little more
或者你不应该成为一名心理学家。第三个原因，也许你已经是一位父母，或者你想在未来几年内成为父母。对于这一点，我会说，别忘了，我们采访过Rose Dunstan，她当时是一名临床心理学实习生，也是一位母亲。如果你觉得这可能有用，请务必查看那一集。那是第25集。你知道，我是一位母亲，我在完成培训后才有了孩子，主要是因为我之前没有遇到想一起生孩子的伴侣。否则，我自己的旅程可能看起来会不同。我真正能说的只是我现在为人父母的经历，那是在获得资格之后。孩子们确实会改变你的优先事项。他们确实会让事情变得稍微
complicated. They do mean that you need to plan more in advance. But, you know, the other day, I wrote six chapters of a book in two hours because that is the time I had available. If that had been write an assignment and I had two hours, I would probably have got the bulk of what I needed to do done in two hours. Whereas when I was training, if I'd had an assignment and I had a whole week to write it, it would have taken me a whole week. You know, I think what erringting does is it helps you identify the gaps where you've got to be able to get things done and it empowers you to get them done. Now, of course, that's if your child is well enough. It's if you've got childcare. But, you know, a training course and counselling
复杂一些。他们确实意味着你需要提前做更多计划。但是，你知道，前几天，我在两个小时内写了六章书，因为那就是我可用的时间。如果那是写作业，而我有两个小时，我可能已经完成了我需要做的大部分工作。而当我在接受培训时，如果我有一个作业，并且有一整周的时间来写，我会花掉整整一周。你知道，我认为为人父母所做的是，它帮助你识别出你必须完成任务的空隙，并赋予你完成它们的动力。当然，这前提是你的孩子身体健康。前提是你得有托儿服务。但是，你知道，培训课程和咨询
trainee doctorates, you are having to do placement hours, you're having to do university time, you are having to do often work on the side to be able to afford to live, you know, you're having to do assignments and the same with obviously clinical psychology and forensic psychology. What I would say is if you're a parent already, you do need to have enough hours in your day to be able to do all of the things that you need to do. So sometimes it's possible to to do your training over a longer period of time but you would usually still be doing it full-time you know so you can have maternity leave or paternity leave or parenting leave or adoption leave but at that point you are expected ordinarily as far as I'm aware to come back and do it full
实习博士学位，你必须完成实习时间，必须完成大学时间，通常还得在业余时间工作以维持生计，你知道，你必须完成作业，临床心理学和法医心理学显然也是如此。我想说的是，如果你已经是一位父母，你确实需要在一天中有足够的时间来完成你需要做的所有事情。所以有时可以在更长的时间内完成培训，但你通常仍然是全职进行的，你知道，所以你可以休产假、陪产假、育儿假或领养假，但在那之后，据我所知，通常要求你回来全职
time so you do need to have enough hours in the day to be able to do it and to be able to get it done and to pass what you need to do but it is possible to be a parent or even to become a parent whilst you are training to be a psychologist and speaking as a qualified psychologist, it most definitely is possible to be a parent when you are working as a qualified psychologist. So I have to confess the most I've ever worked as a parent is four days a week. For me, it did feel essentially like I was doing five days of work in four. But when I had my second child, I went down to three days a week and that definitely made me feel more part-time but of course that does come with a drop in salary which feels like a bit of a kicker but I once worked with a forensic psychologist who didn't at that time have any
工作。所以你确实需要在一天中有足够的时间来完成它，并能够完成它并通过你需要做的考核。但成为一名心理学家并在培训期间成为父母，甚至在成为合格的心理学家后成为父母，都是完全可能的。所以我必须承认，作为父母，我工作最多的时候是每周四天。对我来说，这本质上感觉就像我在四天内完成了五天的工作。但当我有了第二个孩子时，我减少到每周三天，这确实让我感觉更像兼职了，但当然，这伴随着薪水的下降，感觉有点像个打击。但我曾经与一位法医心理学家共事，她当时没有任何
children and still only worked four days and just had that one day a week for herself, which at the time I found it really hard to get my head around that she'd requested that and she didn't have anything else to do. I was like, what do you do? Like, what do you do with that day? She goes, whatever I like. And I couldn't get my head around why you wouldn't want more money and to work full time. I don't know why I didn't get it. I get it now. I get it now. So yes, that obviously has a financial implication if you do work less, but it can help you have a little bit more time for yourself. It can help you have a little bit more time for your children if obviously you do have children. And for me, it assuaged some of the guilt that other people were looking after my child or children
孩子，却仍然只工作四天，每周只留出一天给自己，当时我真的很难理解她为什么要那样要求，而且她也没有其他事情要做。我当时想，你做什么？你那一天做什么？她说，做任何我喜欢的事。我无法理解为什么你不想赚更多的钱并全职工作。我不知道为什么我当时不明白。我现在明白了。我现在明白了。所以是的，如果你工作得少，显然会有经济影响，但它可以帮助你多一点时间给自己。如果显然你有孩子，它可以帮助你多一点时间陪伴孩子。对我来说，这减轻了一些关于别人照顾我孩子的时间比我多的内疚感。
more than I was. You you know I really loved my mummy days um so I used to have Wednesday off which was really nice because a really nice break in the week it meant I had Saturday and Sunday went in for two days had a day with me and my little boy and there was only us at the time and my husband of course but he was at work um and then I went in for a Thursday and a Friday and it was marvellous and then when I went three days a week I had Wednesdays and Thursdays off and it just was so good so good I loved that I think back to that very fondly and it just meant that I was fully committed as a psychologist on the days I was there and then you know I loved being a parent and having the chance to do more of the school runs when they were a thing
你知道，我真的很喜欢我的“妈妈日”。我过去常在周三休息，这真的很棒，因为周中有一个很好的休息。这意味着我有周六和周日，周一和周二去上班，有一天是我和我小儿子在一起，当时只有我们俩，当然还有我丈夫，但他去上班了。然后我周四和周五去上班，这太美妙了。后来当我每周工作三天时，我有周三和周四休息，这真是太好了，太好了。我喜欢那样，我回想起来非常怀念。这意味着我在上班的日子里作为心理学家是全身心投入的，然后，你知道，我喜欢为人父母，有机会在他们上学时做更多的接送工作，
or go to baby and child groups do all those things you know swimming lessons you know baby sensory gymnastics like just being a mummy and watching my children grow which was really really important to me so you definitely can be a psychologist and a parent I am living proof let's take a little break here to listen to a jingle about one of my books and I hope you enjoy it and I'll see you very soon If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book.
或者去参加亲子小组，做所有那些事情，你知道，游泳课，你知道，婴儿感官体操，就像只是做一个妈妈，看着我的孩子们成长，这对我来说真的非常非常重要。所以你绝对可以成为一名心理学家和父母，我就是活生生的证明。让我们在这里休息一下，听听关于我其中一本书的广告歌，希望你喜欢，我们很快再见。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。充满了将帮助你获得资格的课程和经验。所以来看看吧，就在这本书里。
It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective Welcome back. In the first half of the episode, we were thinking about three common reasons why people might have been told or might believe they are not cut out for psychology. Let's plow on with reason number four is issues of physical health, or maybe even that you are a wheelchair user. Now, I think and hope we are very much moving to a more inclusive, less ableist perspective and viewpoint on this. And if you are a regular listener or watcher on YouTube, you might well recall that we very recently met Dr. Yvonne Waft, who is a wheelchair user.
这是《临床心理学家集体》。这是《临床心理学家集体》。欢迎回来。在节目的前半部分，我们思考了人们可能被告知或可能相信自己不适合心理学的三个常见原因。让我们继续讨论第四个原因，即身体健康问题，或者甚至是你是一名轮椅使用者。现在，我认为并希望我们正在向一种更具包容性、更少歧视残障人士的视角和观点转变。如果你是常客或YouTube观众，你可能还记得我们最近刚刚采访了Yvonne Waft博士，她是一位轮椅使用者。
We also met Gavin Clark in episode 111 and we have him coming up again in 119 and he is a wheelchair user. We also met Gavin Clark in episode 111. And we have him coming up again in 119. And he is a wheelchair user. And so hopefully, at least what we're doing with this podcast is we are opening your eyes and your vista for what psychologists look like, you know, they don't all walk on two legs. Some of them wheeling in badass wheelchairs. You know, that is what modern psychologists look like. And of course, they might well have more difficult journeys, different kind of different landscape to navigate in order to get to be working in psychology. So Yvonne spoke about kind of in the past that meetings had been on the wrong floor and there was no access for her, you know. But I hope in modern UK, certainly, that this is changing and that when these things are observed, because of course course if there's never been anyone
我们还在第111集采访了Gavin Clark，我们会在119集再次邀请他，他也是一位轮椅使用者。我们还在第111集采访了Gavin Clark。我们会在119集再次邀请他。他也是一位轮椅使用者。所以希望，至少我们通过这个播客所做的是，我们正在开阔你的视野，让你看到心理学家是什么样子的，你知道，他们并不都是用两条腿走路的。有些人坐着酷炫的轮椅。你知道，这就是现代心理学家的样子。当然，他们可能确实有更艰难的旅程，需要导航不同的景观才能成为心理学家。所以Yvonne谈到了过去会议在错误的楼层，没有无障碍设施，你知道。但我希望在现代英国，当然，这种情况正在改变，当这些事情被观察到时，因为当然，如果团队中从来没有人
who's a wheelchair user in the team before the building is just not equipped for it that necessarily these questions haven't cropped up but once they are noticed and observed I hope that that action can be taken so that everybody can comfortably use and deliver services, regardless of whether they walk, whether they use a stick, whether they use a frame, or whether they use wheels. So that is our reason four. Reason five is linked to pay and esteem and respect. You know know maybe someone has told you you're not a proper doctor you know you're not really that important or is it really worth accruing all of that student debt just to sit around and hear people's problems you know I don't think you ought to do that perhaps you ought to focus on being a medical doctor perhaps you ought to focus on being a medical doctor. Perhaps you ought to focus on something where
是轮椅使用者，建筑设备不齐全，这些问题不一定会浮现。但一旦它们被注意到和观察到，我希望能够采取行动，以便每个人都能舒适地使用和提供服务，无论他们是走路、使用拐杖、使用助行架，还是使用轮椅。所以这就是我们的第四个原因。第五个原因与薪水、地位和尊重有关。你知道，也许有人告诉你“你不是真正的医生”，“你不是那么重要”，或者“仅仅为了坐着听别人的问题而背负所有学生债务真的值得吗？”你知道，我不认为你应该这样做，也许你应该专注于成为一名医学医生。也许你应该专注于成为一名医学医生。也许你应该专注于某些
you're going to be more lucrative like law or accountancy, you know, but you get to do what you want to do and what feels like it lights you up and excites you. And that's kind of regardless of what your family, what your friends, maybe what other people in your circle or even in your teams might think. You get to do, you get to strive for doing what you want to do. And sometimes, you know, having difficult conversations can be useful in terms of advocating for ourselves. And I know if you come from a family that's kind of very set in what its expectations of you are, that can be challenging. But it doesn't make you wrong for wanting to do what you want to do. And ultimately, it is your life. We're not living our lives for our parents, for our grandparents. You know, we are also growing up in different times than they were, and we were
更赚钱的领域，比如法律或会计，你知道，但你可以做你想做的事，做那些让你感到振奋和兴奋的事。这在某种程度上与你的家人、朋友、你圈子里的其他人甚至团队里的人怎么想无关。你可以去做，你可以努力去做你想做的事。有时，你知道，进行艰难的对话在为自己辩护方面是有用的。我知道如果你来自一个对你期望非常固定的家庭，那可能会很有挑战性。但这并不意味着你想做你想做的事是错的。归根结底，这是你的人生。我们不是为了父母、祖父母而活。你知道，我们成长的时代也与他们不同，我们
allowed to make different choices. And maybe, I don't know, maybe this is a sexism thing as well. Maybe they think women shouldn't be working. That is still around in some cultures, in some families. That's still some people's experience. And that is not true either. Regardless of your gender, you can be a psychologist. And so I hope that is useful if that's a message you needed to hear. Reason number six is about career progression. You're not going to move up the ladder. There's not enough. You know, you'll be band seven, you'll be band eight.
被允许做出不同的选择。也许，我不知道，也许这还涉及性别歧视。也许他们认为女性不应该工作。在某些文化、某些家庭中，这种情况依然存在。这仍然是某些人的经历。这也是不对的。无论你的性别如何，你都可以成为一名心理学家。所以我希望如果你需要听到这个信息，它会有所帮助。第六个原因关于职业发展。你不会在阶梯上向上移动。没有足够的空间。你知道，你将是7级，你将是8级。
You know, you'll struggle to get much beyond that. It's a bit boring. It's not diverse enough. You you know what can you possibly do you're just sitting in a chair all day how's that going to be enough for you to which I would say that's just not true you know I look at psychologists you know even my own career I see clients for therapy. I do this brilliant podcast. If you're watching on YouTube, like and subscribe. Share this episode. Tell your friends. If you're listening on Apple or Spotify, please do rate and review. radio, print journalism, online journalism. Like my career is so diverse and so broad. And I see, you know, educational psychologists doing similar things. I see counselling psychologists. So my friend and colleague, Dr. Tara Quinn-Girillo, who we recently co-authored the book Talking Heads, Your Guide to Finding a Qualified Therapist in the UK was published and she's doing brilliant things as well. You know, you are not limited. It is not
你知道，你很难超越那个水平。这有点无聊。它不够多样化。你，你知道，你到底能做什么？你整天只是坐在椅子上，这怎么能满足你呢？对此，我会说这根本不是真的。你知道，我看着心理学家，你知道，即使是我自己的职业生涯，我为客户提供治疗。我做这个精彩的播客。如果你在YouTube上观看，请点赞并订阅。分享这一集。告诉你的朋友。如果你在Apple或Spotify上收听，请务必评分和评论。广播、纸媒、网络媒体。我的职业生涯是如此多样化和广泛。我看到，你知道，教育心理学家在做类似的事情。我看到咨询心理学家。所以我的朋友兼同事Tara Quinn-Girillo博士，我们最近合著了《Talking Heads: Your Guide to Finding a Qualified Therapist in the UK》一书，她也在做着出色的事情。你知道，你没有受到限制。它不是
a little box that you will find yourself in. Even in the teams, if you end up employed, there is still diversity in that career. You can still look to carve out niches for yourself. And you can also move jobs as well. So I went from being a CAMHS clinician for four years to then moving to become primarily because I wanted to work closer to home and it was a pay rise to then working in an adult mental health service. And it was a very big change, a very big jump. But I guess I was looking at the needs of myself and my family at that time. And it was a very big change, a very big jump. But I guess I was looking at the needs of myself and my family at that time. And it's been transformational for me. So had I not had a family, I might well have continued in CAMHS. And who knows where I would be? I loved my role in CAMHS,
一个你会发现自己被困住的小盒子。即使在团队中，如果你最终被雇佣，这个职业中仍然存在多样性。你仍然可以寻求为自己开辟利基市场。你也可以换工作。所以我从一名CAMHS（儿童和青少年心理健康服务）临床医生做了四年，然后转行，主要是因为我想在离家更近的地方工作，而且那是加薪，然后去了一家成人心理健康服务机构工作。这是一个非常大的变化，一个非常大的跨越。但我猜我当时是在考虑自己和家人的需求。这是一个非常大的变化，一个非常大的跨越。但我猜我当时是在考虑自己和家人的需求。这对我来说是变革性的。所以如果我没有家庭，我可能早就继续在CAMHS工作了。谁知道我会去哪里呢？我热爱我在CAMHS的角色，
but I also love where I've ended up. So it is a broad career. It is a long time that we will be working in it that said please do check out episode 109 of the podcast which was myself and ian dempsey an independent financial advisor where we were looking at pensions let's make sure that you are going to yeah have enough money when you get to retirement it's a great episode and it's doing really good things on youtube specifically so go and check that out there is absolutely not limited growth i know of people working in band nine i know of qualified clinical psychologists who have gone on to work at directorate level in nhs trusts it's infinitely possible there is growth. If you have the drive, I would say psychology has got the opportunities for you. Last but not least, reason number seven,
但我也热爱我最终所在的地方。所以这是一个广泛的职业。我们将在这个职业中工作很长时间。话虽如此，请务必查看播客的第109集，那是我和独立财务顾问Ian Dempsey讨论养老金的节目。让我们确保你，是的，在退休时有足够的钱。这是一集很棒的节目，在YouTube上表现特别好，所以去看看吧。绝对没有增长限制。我知道有人在9级工作，我知道有合格的临床心理学家在NHS信托基金中担任董事级别。这是完全可能的，有增长空间。如果你有动力，我会说心理学有适合你的机会。最后但同样重要的是，第七个原因，
it's a thankless job. You're never going to make a difference. Mental health is too big for little old you to make a big enough ripple. That I would say it doesn't matter even if you make small ripples, even if you just do one-to-one work with clients and that makes a difference, that's enough. How many times in our lives do we get bored of hearing if I hadn't done this work with you, I would have ended my own life? That is incredibly powerful and that matters. Recall some stats on cost of suicide to the economy because, of course, when a life ends, that means they're no longer earning, they're no longer working, they're no longer paying tax, they're no longer buying things from the corner shop, they're no longer going to
这是一份吃力不讨好的工作。你永远不会有所作为。心理健康对你这个小人物来说太大了，无法产生足够大的涟漪。对此，我会说，即使你只产生小的涟漪，即使你只是与客户进行一对一的工作，并且这产生了影响，那也足够了。在我们的一生中，我们有多少次厌倦了听到“如果我没有和你一起做这项工作，我就已经结束自己的生命了”？这非常有力，这很重要。回顾一些关于自杀对经济成本的统计数据，因为，当然，当一个生命结束时，意味着他们不再赚钱，不再工作，不再纳税，不再从街角商店买东西，不再去
supermarkets, they're no longer going to gyms. You know, there's a massive financial impact and a loss to society for each and every person who ends their life by suicide. And that's not supposed to sound like a criticism. It's not. It's that this isn't just a loss to families and loved ones who care about this person. This is a societal loss, you know. It's a loss of hope. It's a loss of that person's life being different. It's a loss of them being able to do something really incredible for their community, for the world in their living years. So obviously, sometimes things go on after people have ended their own lives that go around them as part of people setting up trusts or charities. But how wonderful it would be if that person had been better supported to go on to do these
超市，不再去健身房。你知道，对于每一个自杀的人来说，这对社会都有巨大的经济影响和损失。这并不是要听起来像是一种批评。不是的。而是这不仅仅是对关心这个人的家庭和亲人的损失。这是一种社会损失，你知道。这是一种希望的丧失。这是一种那个人的生活本可以不同的丧失。这是一种他们无法在有生之年为社区、为世界做一些真正不可思议的事情的丧失。所以很明显，有时在人们结束自己的生命后，事情会继续围绕他们进行，作为人们建立信托或慈善机构的一部分。但如果那个人能得到更好的支持，在活着的时候继续做这些
incredible things whilst they were living we do great things psychologists are great whichever profession whichever discipline it is that you want to go into it's just brilliant i've said it before i will say it again i have the best job in the world. I get to do so many brilliant things and it's honestly a privilege. It's a pleasure. You can go as big as you want to go. You can do what I do. You can write books. You can do media to impact on as many people as you like, or you can keep it as little as you like, but it all matters. And thank you for doing what you do. So we've taken a whistle-stop tour through seven reasons that you might have been told, or that you might believe, means that you cannot have a career in psychology. I'm really hoping
不可思议的事情，那该多好啊。我们做着伟大的事情，心理学家是伟大的，无论你想进入哪个职业，哪个学科，这都很棒。我以前说过，我还会再说一遍，我拥有世界上最好的工作。我能做这么多精彩的事情，这真的是一种荣幸。这是一种快乐。你可以随心所欲地做大。你可以做我做的事。你可以写书。你可以通过媒体影响尽可能多的人，或者你可以保持尽可能小，但这一切都很重要。感谢你所做的一切。所以我们进行了一次旋风式的巡回，了解了七个你可能被告知，或者你可能相信的，意味着你不能从事心理学职业的原因。我真的希望
we have debunked those myths. And if you would like to connect with me, please do come and do so. There will be a QR code on screen if you're watching on YouTube. But basically, I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. Please do check out the videos on screen that are being suggested to you if you're watching on YouTube. Please do consider coming along to the Aspiring Psychology community, which is my free Facebook group. And if you need a little bit more support or guidance, please do consider the Aspiring Psychologist membership. People are getting great results and finding that they even get assistant psychologist roles because they are feeling so much more competent and confident in their abilities. I will look
我们已经揭穿了那些神话。如果你想与我联系，请务必这样做。如果你在YouTube上观看，屏幕上会有二维码。但基本上，我到处都是“Dr. Marianne Trent”。如果你在YouTube上观看，请务必查看屏幕上建议给你的视频。请考虑加入“有抱负的心理学社区”，这是我的免费Facebook群组。如果你需要更多的支持或指导，请考虑“有抱负的心理学家会员资格”。人们正在获得很好的结果，并发现他们甚至获得了助理心理学家的职位，因为他们对自己的能力感到更加胜任和自信。我将
forward to coming to you with our next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast which will be around your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about
期待在《有抱负的心理学家》播客的下一集中与你见面，内容将围绕你获得资格的途径。这是《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，我是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。达到目标有这么多不同的途径，这让我感到惊讶，而且没有完美的途径可以成为一名心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对
becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这只是为了让你安心，一切都会好起来的，但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。